(joyful music)
(laughing)
- Today, we're gonna be
trying real Pilgrim food.
- I'm not excited.
- It's gonna be great.
- I don't really know
anything about the Pilgrims.
In my head, have you seen The Village?
They're kind of are like that.
- They landed in Massachusetts right?
- Is that Massachusetts?
- Northeast?
- I thought that was Virginia.
- No Erin! (laughing)
- They kind of destroyed
everything that matters.
- Pilgrim food equals probably
disgusting, so we'll see.
- Here we go.
(joyful music)
- Stewed.
- That doesn't sound American at all.
- Pompion.
- It looks like spaghetti
squash and it smells like ass.
- Mmm, it's good, you don't like it?
- The texture.
(laughing)
- It's not as bad as I thought.
I actually do genuinely think
that, that wasn't so bad.
- Mhm.
- I'm surprised, I think I'm kind of
impressed with them actually.
- I literally didn't have lunch
and like I'm going to
continue eating this.
You don't need it back right?
- Samp, that's not a name of a thing.
- I don't really like
the smell of this one.
- What is this? (laughs)
- Mm, it tastes like a wet corn muffin.
(gasps)
- Okay.
- This is good.
- I don't know if you can see
this but it's not moving so.
- Oh wow, it's like really
staying there, there it goes.
- Oh!
- Down for the mush.
- I'm down for the mush.
- I don't know if I'd eat it
again but I don't hate it.
- I'd eat it again. (laughs)
- Ooh!
- Pancakes?
(buzzing)
- Okay.
- I'm stoked.
- I'm kinda interested in this.
- Ooh, I'm really excited.
- Oh god, oh you ruined it.
- Hm.
Hm!
- I don't believe they had icing sugar.
- Once you realize or like accept the fact
that it's not a pancake,
it's like let's eat this.
- It's fine right?
- Yeah.
- I really wasn't mad at this at all.
Like good job Pilgrims.
- Definitely not mad at it,
no emotions like, towards it.
- I can't stop, do you need
these for the next people?
- It wasn't anything to dread,
that was all completely fine.
- Way more mush than I was expecting.
- Very, very mushy but not as nasty
as I thought it was gonna be.
- Pilgrims are boring
and their food is boring.
- I don't think I would
survive as a Pilgrim.
- I need technology way too much for that.
- I'm also scared of animals as well.
(laughing)
- 2017 over 1617.
- Same.
Same.
- Wasn't there like
something with the Caribbean?
- Yeah, that was slaves.
- Oh no!
(laughing)
- Ugh, it's such a dark
history, every part of it.